hey 42 here in 2008 an inmate in
Colorado convicted of armed robbery was
released from prison 19 years to it due
to a clerical error he could have
believed his look and was determined to
get his life back on track he got a job
got married her kids went to church
every week and started coaching youth
soccer after six years of making the
most of his accidental freedom
authorities realized their mistake and
sent him back to prison in America
prison inmates are accidentally released
too early disturbingly often also in
Colorado another inmate was mistakenly
released for years early their story
wasn't as pleasant
while started prison he killed the state
correction chief when he knocked on the
inmates door what even in makes serve
their entire sentence or is perhaps what
up early for good behavior what are the
chances of them reoffending does the
prison system actually work there are
currently over 9 million people
incarcerated in prisons worldwide half
of that number is held in just three
countries the US China and Russia the US
has the most prisoners by far with over
2.3 million adults behind bars within
its borders America has just 5% of the
world's population but over 1/4 of its
prison population so does this mass
incarceration work no absolutely not in
fact it does quite the opposite prison
only creates more crime and more
prisoners it is a completely self
criminai zhing system imagine if I told
you I had a fantastic new plan to stop
crime we take all the people after being
naughty and put them into a building
where they can't leave and all they can
do to keep themselves occupied is talk
to all the other criminals and learn
learn how to commit more complex crimes
and get away with that and plan their
next grand criminal escapades once they
are released
they may even form coalition's crime is
even practiced on one another inside
prisons in whatever ways possible some
rise to the top and become kingpins or
gang leaders that orchestrate new crimes
on the outside from inside prison many
experts have labeled prisons as crime
schools and it's easy to see why this is
an excerpt from a letter by a UK
prisoner called Ben that was entered
into a yearly prison of writing
competition the day I was sent to prison
I learned how to steal cars still in
shock from the jury's verdict I was led
from the courthouse into a white van a
convict in another compartment was
boasting of how he drove off and sold
luxury Moses BMWs Mercedes on the like
he used an electronic device to override
them immobilizers unseen figures from
other compartments called out questions
how long does it take what models does
it work on how can I get one
I listened intrigued I have never stolen
anything and I didn't intend to then
again it sounded so easy so then it's no
surprise that the recidivism rate is so
high in the u.s. almost 70% of prisoners
are really within three years of being
released and 77% re-arrested within five
years and that's just the people that
are caught me committing crimes sure
when it comes to any kind of prison
statistics America is always the worst
example but other countries are not far
behind in the UK 47 percent of prisoners
riaf end within three years but there is
one country that has broke them all and
has reduced their recidivism rate to
just 20 percent but we'll talk about
that in a minute
hatred breeds hatred and violence causes
violence people who have been hurt are
the most likely to go on to hurt
and as long as the prison system is
based on violence and hardline
punishment it will continue to create
more violence and more crime the world's
leading psychologists have long agreed
that confining humans in cages with
minimal human interaction and sometimes
with no human interaction whatsoever is
unimaginably damaging to one's long-term
mental health it creates deep mental
wounds it dehumanizes people and
devalues a person's sense of worth and
once you take that away more crime can
seem like the only way forward after
release in prison but by far one of the
most damaging effects of prison on both
prisoners and society is isolation
especially can family members prison has
a way a personal support network and
research shows that a number one factor
that determines if a person will rear
fender or not after release is whether
they have support from their family and
friends prison makes this level of
support which is required practically
unachievable but the wounds go even
deeper in America 2.7 million children
have a parent inside prison research has
shown that when a child loses their
mother or father figure to prison with
minimal contact they are many many times
more likely to grow up to commit crime
themselves so not only is prison causing
adults to Rhea friend it's also
preparing the next generation to be
criminals too so what's the answer
it's very well saying that prison
doesn't work but surely the only real
alternative that doesn't violate every
human rights law is allowing murderers
rapists and other criminals to roam the
streets or is it remember earlier I
mentioned that there is a country where
the reoffending rate is just 20% well
what if I also told you that this
mystical place also has one of the
lowest incarceration rates in the world
they have put only 70 out of every
100,000 best
behind bars compared to the world's
leading incarcerator America which has
put 716 of every 100,000 of their
citizens in prison over ten times as
many welcome to a magical land called
Norway where the air is clean the food
is pickled and the streets are
ridiculously safe Norway is officially
the sixth safest country in the world
according to the Legacy and prosperity
index at 2060 joining the ranks of other
Scandinavian countries and places like
Singapore and Japan sure
Norway has had it's upsets in recent
years but overall it's still one of the
safest places to live but how can this
be when they incarcerate such a tiny
percentage of that population surely the
only way to keep the public safe is to
lock up all the criminals of life so
that they can't commit any more crimes
well makes sense in theory but the most
important factor is what happens after a
prisoner is released you see there isn't
a constant supply of new criminals it's
estimated that only 15% of the
population of any country will ever
commit a crime during their lives and
the vast majority of major crimes that
are worthy of prison time are committed
by an even smaller group of constitute
reoffended in most countries at least so
then it makes sense that if you reform
that tiny pool of people that are
continually committing crimes over and
over again by turning them into fully
functioning upstanding members of
society then the prison population will
naturally decrease along with the crime
rate instead of increasing every year as
it has in America and that is exactly
how Norway has created one of the safest
countries in the world and achieved one
of the lowest prison populations by
mastering the art of
Kamilah tation in fact Norway's
rehabilitation methods have been so
successful that their prison population
is falling every year and so is crime
whilst the rest of the world is busy
building more and more prisons what my
method of rehabilitation is quite
unusual unlike in most developed
countries the prison authorities don't
stick you in a white room and have a
patronizing conversation with you about
how you will manage on the outside they
don't make you absolutely promise that
you'll get a job and not suit anyone
what they do is actually refreshingly
simple and obvious they treat you like a
normal person
this may seem unfair after all these are
criminals not puppies we're talking
about when you think about it why
shouldn't criminals be treated like
normal people and given proper
accommodation jobs and social lives they
may have messed up but your basic human
needs don't suddenly change when you get
sentenced and to strip away the
essential things that make you human
only serves to cause further mental
damage to a person increasing the
likelihood of them committing violent
crime in the future
welcome to hold a maximum-security
prison in Norway that houses the
country's most violent criminals all
inmates are treated the same no matter
their crime there is no pointless and
damaging solitary confinement this is an
inmate Cell it's nice and roomy they all
have unrestricted windows to the outside
we've lost views of greenery and forests
and plenty of natural light and it's all
that they don't have to share it with
anyone there's a flat-screen TV in every
room private shower mini-fridge and
double luxuries
I've definitely stayed in worse hotel
rooms there's a cookery school where all
inmates are taught how to cook to
themselves a shop and kitchen so inmates
can buy their own ingredients and make
their own meals or cook for their prison
buddies and yes there are plenty of
sharp knives all prisoners are free to
leave their cells at any time
enjoy the prisons various facilities
such as a gym sports hall with a rock
climbing wall outdoor sports field music
studio where inmates are encouraged to
make music that is often played by local
radio stations a woodworking studio a
library with CDs DVDs and games not only
our prisoners encouraged to spend time
outside their cells but they are
actually paid to do so prisoners are
given an incentive of 53 kronor
or 7 dollars per day to leave their
cells and socialize all inmates are
offered the opportunity of education and
paid jobs within the prison nobody has
ever tried to escape from hold'em prison
and incidents of violence are extremely
rare Norway is a vast beautiful country
and in Norway taking away a person's
freedom is considered enough of a
punishment in itself for any crime so
instead of spending the person's entire
prison sentence punishing them verver
Norwegian prison focused solely on
rehabilitation and integration within
society to try and repair the mental
damage that may have caused them to
commit the crime in the first place this
may be too progressive for some people
and it does raise an ethical concern is
it right and just that a person who
potentially murdered a friend or family
member of yours should be treated as
though there is a five-star retreat at
the cost of the taxpayers number left
foot way with you pragmatically it makes
a lot of sense this prison has achieved
an incredibly low recidivism rate of
just 20 percent the lowest in the world
and this in turn lowers crime rate every
year it's better for society and better
for the economy this is all helped along
further by the incredible support a
Norwegian ex-prisoner receives after
being released various agencies give
their support and check up on them
regularly making sure they have
accommodation a support network and
crucially a job contrary to America
where a criminal record
and for a minor event is a big black
mark on your CV and permanent government
records which ensures you will never
ever get a proper job again and you can
never develop a career the rest of your
life it goes without saying that if you
take away a criminal's chance to get a
job they're probably going to turn to
crime to film themselves well I'll be
damned in norway ex-prisoners are also
given free health care education and
among dated pension just like any other
citizen whilst many around the world
have criticised no way - being too soft
on crime the numbers speak for
themselves with a 20% recidivism rate
punishments just doesn't work and it
doesn't provide a deterrent punishment
only exacerbates the problem many
countries have made a compelling case to
prove that Norway has proven that the
only way to solve the crime issue is to
work with criminals to achieve a better
future and Norway have taken this one
huge step further
holdin prison may seem like a paradise
to many people I mean most students
across the world probably live in worse
conditions but there's a prison that's
even more luxurious a place that would
give you a last holiday abroad every one
for his money
welcome to Buster Island Norway a
beautiful secluded island lodge with
forests and Warner with some of the most
adil ik beaches in the world just 50
miles south of Oslo but this isn't a
five-star Holiday Resort this is a
prison bus toy island is Norway's
minimum security prison and the most
luxurious prison in the world but this
isn't where the small-time crooks are
held buster is haunting murderers
rapists and child birth
there are no ones no chain no cells or
razor wire no walls prisoners are free
to roam the island are now leisure and
enjoy bike rides or go to the beach or a
dip in the ocean whenever they feel like
prisoners live in shared apartments and
everyone has their own private bedroom
with a lock and key even the prison
guards don't have a key to the prisoners
bedroom
the wooden houses are flush with TVs
computers musical instruments and other
luxuries island inmates can take three
classes and music cookery computer
studies craftsmanship or academia to
prepare them for work after their
release they can apply for jobs on the
island most work on the farm looking
after the animals or using heavy
machinery and growing their own food to
feed the other Islanders
they live within that own ecosystem and
the island is fully self-sufficient
unsustainable the island hosts around
the 120 inmates with only 5 prison
guards keeping watch overnight
even during the day bein made vastly
outnumber the prison staff who say that
they have a great relationship with all
the inmates and they're regularly
invited inside their homes for coffee
under chat when passing by one of the
previous residents the vastly higher was
sent here after he chopped up two people
with a chainsaw whilst on the island
well he was allowed to work in the
forest with the chainsaw and now for
recreation there is a sauna tennis court
plenty of fishing spots and horseback
riding there is a resident head chef
that cooks up restaurant quality dishes
for anyone who doesn't want to cook for
themselves some longer-term residents
have the freedom to leave the island on
boat and go to work at real jobs on the
mainland five days a week no one has
ever tried to escape from bastoy Island
well why would you this is essentially a
holiday camp for criminals that many non
criminals will pay good money to stay up
this infuriate many people why should we
coddle and pamper violent criminals
well in the words of head psychologist
in bastoy prison and its ex-governor are
Nilsen if we have created a holiday camp
for criminals here so what we should
reduce the risk of reoffending because
if we don't then what's the point of
punishment except for leaning towards
the primitive side of humanity and it's
difficult to argue with him when vastly
Island prisons we offend the rate is
just 16% even lower than the already
impressive Norwegian national average of
20% the maximum prison sentence in
Norway is just 21 years even the
terrorist Anders Breivik who in 2011
killed 8 people with a van bomb in Oslo
then chillingly shot dead 69 people as a
summer camp was only given a sentence of
21 years upon entering the courtroom the
judge shook Breivik's hands and smiled
at him as his customary in Norway this
act and his short sentence was greeted
with mass skepticism and disgust by the
world media he is the biggest challenge
Norway the Dilek prison system has ever
faced will it prove as successful at
reforming him as it has many more before
him only time will tell whether you
agree with Norway's views on
rehabilitation or not you have to hand
it to them they are doing something
right they have accomplished one of the
safest societies in the world without
ever really punishing anyone
and when hardline punitive treatment in
America and other countries has only
made problems far worse and increased
violence by both criminals and the
authorities year-on-year perhaps it is
time for the world to pay attention
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please click here to support
me on patreon not only will you be
helping me to make better videos but
you'll also get some really cool rewards
like t-shirts and posters every month
and you'll get early access to all my
videos click here to watch another
and if you haven't already don't forget
to subscribe